this is rewind for a second because if
you recall by the style listen I said
look it's not the medical thinking idea
it's not just about saying hey there are
numbers but it's about asking questions
of those numbers trying to see are there
patterns in those numbers and why those
patents part of the way there are
happens are everywhere and they're
beautiful one of the most beautiful ones
you can see it's right over there on the
hour left of the room there's something
you see a triangle shape I encourage you
some of you can see this one as well as
a bigger one this is interesting shape
going on here and it's built with
numbers i encourage you at the end or
any time you're in this room just go
have a closer look at this post and see
what's going on I'm going to show you a
pattern here first that's no crime of
last year now make one back for us
brilliant yes Pascal triangle loads of
fun things this other way if you come on
really the question see their tiny tiny
numbers in there and you'll see asker's
frame women but this is clearly
something else going on so how can we
understand it why is it that when i add
odd numbers and i put them in order i
end up with school hairs what why didn't
you do that now I don't you want your
diagram he's sort of a general lesson
point diagrams are super useful diagram
by your friend on diagram actually I
like a pair of glasses they help you see
things that you otherwise cannot see you
can't imagine okay so we're going to use
this diagram here this bunch of squares
the floor and i'm going to show you with
the threat with the help of my friends
are counting stones over the car why is
now here's the trigger instead of
arranging them you know we didn't you
know pairs of rows like this okay it's
kind of a bit of a pain having on number
and hanging on one out but actually that
odd one out is really really useful I
don't think oh I'm the owner that's bit
of a pain Oh burnouts pal watch your
even step numbers
the drill is they exactly match up
there's six and you can see their nut
job right if I put another one on you
get this kind of situation but what if I
don't what two roads what if I want
something else what if my reading I want
something like two hours you're in that
odd wonder that we said looks funny
there the odd point out is what makes
the two arms of this kind of like sort
of junction of his l it makes it work
the odd one out is needed otherwise you
don't get the shape I wonder if anyone's
cogs are turning up here and seeing what
we can do with this thing watch you've
been probably writing numbers yeah I'm
going to do the same thing we did hear
that i'm going to do it visually i'd
love if you've got two colors there'll
be outstanding you to follow along with
me one that was a bit boring that's fine
here's one right here is my first county
so now what I had three dawn I'm going
to put the cutting stones in but i'm
going to use the superpower of odd
numbers which is that they can able to
do they can make these L shapes in here
can you see is it ll shame I can fit
around using my three bit like Tetris
right and fit it around the one you see
watch how did you hear one two three you
see it look that's how that three it
kind of filled in this square like this
square up here is exactly but we drove
here what's the next online at five that
can feel around the edges want me to use
my next color so if you want your bag
one two three
all right to see this one here in
mathematical thinking say nothing is a
coincidence right there's always
something going wrong here I can keep
going right I can say the next one this
is the last one I do it man when I add
on seven one two three four five six
seven you see the odd numbers have their
own kind of beauty very kind of shape to
them let's finish off this square right
you can now see the next number without
having to go through adding bees all
over again is going to be 5 times 5
let's finish something on dismiss you so
that means i got this square here which
is now 5 by 5 inches high x 25 25
fantastic the last one where go draw
today and then i'm going to ask you to
pack up is the last of these high
modulus which i think for us he is one
two three four five or six so now till
11 right there that last one on fits and
now i have a big square 36